a lot of people are throwing around the  word sedition recently and  unfortunately not for no good reason but  what  is sedition itself well originally as  used in the united states sedition meant  opposing or resisting any law of the  united states or writing anything false  malicious or scandalous about the  president or  congress but because of the first  amendment that doesn't fly  so now the law is codified at 18 usc  2384 which makes it a crime for two or  more people within the united states to  conspire to overthrow or destroy by  force the  government of the united states or to  level war against them to oppose by  force the authority of the united states  government or to take caesar possessed  by force any property of the united  states the next statute makes it a crime  to advocate for the violent overthrow of  the united states government is what we  saw on january 6th actually sedition  well i'm gonna do a full video to find  out so i'll see you  in court